hi hello thank you for such a great
family movie on a friday night i'm
so happy it was so fun but
you realize that when all kids and
parents see this movie you're basically
setting up a 24 hours of yes all around
the world right
that's the whole point that's what we're
hoping like making a national holiday
let's go for it i know so jen this is
something that's near and dear to your
heart you've been doing this for a while
with your family
yeah this is like the most personal
movie i think i've ever
ever put out there this is really a
reflection of motherhood from me
to you um but yes i've been doing these
for a long time and
when you have a lot of people that
you're in charge of and you're trying to
make sure they get to school with their
homework done and in their backpack and
their cleats for soccer and
their ballet shoes and the right snack i
mean there are a lot of guardrails put
up that feel like a lot of nose you kind
of turn into a military
so it's good to just let it go and say
yes for a day
absolutely we started doing yesterdays
on birthdays a couple years ago so when
i told them there was a movie about this
they were so excited they were so
excited oh wow you do more than one a
year
wow my i tip my cap to you i do one
that's it
so edgar is there something that you
wish um
when you were a kid your parents said
yes to all the time
is there something you could go back and
be like i wish they said yes to this
yeah the ice cream the ice cream scene
so as an adult you know and completely
you know
unexpectedly i got to to live my dream
my childhood dream of
eating you know on
advisory amounts of ice cream
you know so yes i mean it was a great
catharsis for me i
loved it you know actually i've i've
i've told janet
and and miguel and and the rest of the
kids that there was this this commercial
when i was a kid growing up in venezuela
of this little this this little kid this
small kid um
um dressed as a as a gentleman and then
and he will be
served scoops and scoops and scoops you
know of of ice cream in a very fancy
restaurant and that commercial
stuck with me all these years so when i
was given
that gigantic bowl of ice cream
this is it this is really is a dream
come true yeah it really is we had so
much fun i mean if you have to eat ice
cream for work what are you gonna do
exactly tell me about that car wash
scene
actually for fun the other day i took
the kids through the car wash i said we
can't go to canada's wonderland but
we're gonna do this hands up in the air
let's go
and then you guys had the scene where
the windows were open and they looked at
me on friday and were like could we do
that and i was like no
big captain no what was it like shooting
that scene
that would be a big no in real life
let's just be clear
the water wouldn't be clean we had clean
water it would be
gross but to shoot it the way we did
it was i would say in a word in two
words
cold and surprising what would you say
edgar yes
it was super cold and it was super fun
and again
ever since i had my first car because
i'm not i'm a freak with cleaning-ness
in general especially with my gadgets
and my car is one of them
so i like my snowboard like everything
super
clean and i'm you know and with the
generals
and with my car especially so
i used to visit i'm used to visit car
wash
you know car washes very often so um
ever since i had my first car i secretly
fantasized
about rolling down the windows so again
this movie it almost feels like they
consulted with people close to me and
then they wrote the stream and they said
this guy's gonna like the movie because
i also love roller coasters i
love them and for some reason i've never
been
to six flags although i've been working
in california for a long time and never
been to one of them
i know poor jen you know she's super
scared of roller coasters but i love
them not my thing
not my thing i love it i love it and i
have to give so much credit to jen
because uh the one that she shot that
scene
in is one of the of the scariest
in that park and i can't tell you she
really did that jen
yeah yeah many times
i cried cheryl i cried during it
between takes i got off my knees were
knocking i cried i said please tell me
we don't have to do it again they said
i mean you're the producer but we need
to do it again and i was like okay i'm
going to do it again but i don't want to
see i thought you would have stunt
double first like some of the flips and
like the roller coaster
okay you're my hero oh no and and then
you have and you have
like her the shot of her and jenna yeah
no right there in front of the camera it
was i mean poor thing she was terrified
because then i
i i i wrote i mean i i went on that ride
with jenna
after we rap that day and it was super
scary i sat down with jenna
in front of the in front of the of the
of the car and it was super scary it was
super scary so
you know again way to go
thank you for this movie thank you for
the roller coaster
and uh it was just really fun guys the
world needs it so thank you
thank you so much i hope your kids love
it thank you yes
they did good thanks you too cheryl bye
you